you know i have criticized mitt romney
in the past
in 2012 i campaigned for not one but two
of his competitors in 2016 i ignored all
his stupid warnings about trump
since that time i have regularly
lambasted him
for holding up good important
republican policy priorities but it
would seem as though
mitt romney is coming around he has just
announced that he will not
hold up president trump's supreme court
nominee
the decision to proceed now with the
president trump's nominee is also
consistent with history
i came down on the side of the
constitution and precedent as i've
studied it
and make the decision on that basis
very good news we're all excited he's
right that the president
is on the side of trump that the
constitution is on the side of trump
i think it's 19 times in u.s history
we've been in this situation
where a president during election year
has to fill a supreme court vacancy
and he's got the white house and he's
got the senate
and 17 out of those 19 times the
nominee has gone through i believe it's
two out of ten times
when either either party has either the
senate
or the white house but not both and
there's a supreme court vacancy during
the fourth year of a presidential
administration only two out of ten times
has that nominee gone through majority
of those times nominee hasn't gone
through so mitt romney's looking at
president he's looking at the
constitution he's saying
okay this is the right thing to do but
what's even more interesting than that
kind of base level analysis
and what he's actually doing is his
further reasoning
for why we need a supreme court nominee
i think it's straightforward in terms of
the qualifications you look for which is
someone who is an expert of the law
someone who has a record of fairness and
judgment that you think is
consistent with the law i prefer
choosing those folks who
are if you will strict constructionist
meaning that they
look at the law itself and the
constitution as opposed to
sort of looking into the sky and pulling
out ideas that they think
may be more appropriate than either the
law of the constitution so
i i recognize that we uh
we may have a court which has more of a
conservative
bent than it's had over the last few
decades
but my liberal friends have over many
decades gotten very used to the idea of
having a liberal court
and that's not written in the stars uh
and i know a lot of people are saying
gosh we don't want that change i
understand
the energy associated with that
perspective
but it's also appropriate for nation
which is if you will center right
uh to have a court which reflects uh
center right points of view which again
are
not changing uh the the law from what it
states
but instead following the law and
following the constitution
he's still a full-throated moderate he
hasn't become some mega
hat wearing trumpy republican he's not a
populist none of that
what mitt romney is doing is making a
moderate case
for trump for trump's priorities for
trump's supreme court nominee
this is a big shift because what we've
been hearing for the whole presidential
election is
trump is extreme he's radical we've
heard this from from even people like
mitt romney
but now with the left burning down the
country with the left willing to torch
our traditions and our political
institutions there is no moderate left
there's no
moderate argument to be made for the
left
or for the democrats and so the only
place for a moderate like mitt to go
is for the republicans for donald trump
for this important priority right now to
shift the balance of the court
center right country we need a
center-right court not a far
extreme left court and that's the only
type of leftism
that's left i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is
men bad women good but michael how
can they say they believe that when
they also say there's no such thing as
either of those yes
this is very confusing because on the
one hand they'll say there's a
patriarchy
and men have oppressed women through all
of history but actually there's no such
thing as men are or women
and sex is not fixed and men can become
women and vice versa and you think well
okay
if there's a patriarchy and horrible
oppression and misogyny all around the
world
and women can become men well why don't
women just become men
and then they don't have to deal with
the oppression actually then they can
become the oppressor class but of course
they don't believe those arguments in
themselves they don't believe
that either there are men or women or
that men can become women
they only believe in power they believe
in making whatever argument
augments their power and and so there's
no objective reality that we're
referring to it's all just a battle of
interest
and a battle of will and this argument i
mean the men and women thing is somewhat
recent
but but the the basis of that argument
that politics is
merely about interest it's not about
reason and argument and objective
reality
that goes back at least a couple hundred
years on the left
but we're very happy now because there
are some people who have been squishy in
the middle
who have you know given in a little bit
to the left even though their premises
are totally wrong
who now because those premises have been
taken to their logical conclusions
they're saying gosh i gotta go with the
guys on the right i don't like trump i
don't like what he stands for i guess
but
he's the more moderate guy now we're
we're also told at the same time
no no no forget about that biden is a
moderate
biden's been a moderate his whole career
hey suburban women vote for joe biden
don't vote for
donald trump joe biden is now making
this argument himself he was asked how
he's going to stop
socialism and the extremism of the
radical left which is torching the
country
what does he say he says look i've been
a moderate my whole career i'm no
socialist
i defeated the socialist talk to the
voters that are worried about
socialism and you raising taxes first of
all i guarantee
a promise i've never broken my word
anyone making less than four hundred
thousand dollars will not see
one single penny in their tax raised
number two i beat the socialist that's
how i got elected that's how i got the
nomination
do i look like a socialist look at my
career my whole career
i am not a socialist he is not a
socialist i agree with that
i am not going to make the argument that
joe biden
even though he's tried to pretend to be
scranton working class
regular old joe for most of his career
is now all of a sudden
a radical marxist or something like that
that's not the problem
the problem is he's so weak
that the socialists and other type of
extremists in the democratic party
are actually the ones calling the shots
it's not that joe biden has all of a
sudden become a radical he's by the way
he's not a moderate either
he's just an empty suit he doesn't
believe in
anything all he wants to do is smile and
smack you on the back
it's actually why i didn't even jump on
the bandwagon of how joe is a sexual
predator because of the hair sniffing
and all that sort of stuff
i don't suspect that that is
actually a sort of sexual impulse of his
i think he's just a glad-handing
politician
who wants to make you feel really
special so you vote for him even though
he doesn't believe in anything he's not
appealing to you
on an ideological or philosophical basis
he's only appealing to you on this
personal level so
if things go to the left he'll go to the
left if things go to the right he'll go
to the right right he's
he's relatively moderate on abortion i
guess for most of his career
now the dems are pro-abortion like super
duper pro-abortion
so he swings all the way in the other
direction says taxpayers should should
fund it
that's that's joe biden which way the
wind blows
there are ideologues behind him though
and the ideologues behind him
right now the ones calling the shots are
radical far
left there was there was one big
endorsement he just picked up from a
communist terrorist which we'll get into
in a second because this this issue of
your taxes going up this issue of your
property being taken away
is a very important one and that means
you got to save your pennies now and the
best way to do that is with pure talk
usa
puretalk usa can save you
so much money on your cell phone you
think that all the money you pay for
your cell phone that's just what you got
to pay
and then the amount goes up every month
and again you don't know how it's going
to
be maybe it's 130 one month maybe 150
another month that's just the way it is
right if you want to get
a t or sprint or t-mobile service and
network and coverage
actually what if i told you you could
get the exact same coverage the exact
same now the exact same towers for half
the price
that's what pure talk usa does costs you
half
no contract no excessive fees how do
they do that well because they don't
have a zillion dollar marketing campaign
and all this crazy infrastructure
they come straight to you they pass the
savings along and they've got customer
service right here in the u.s
you can get for instance unlimited talk
unlimited text two gigs of data four
drum roll please 20 bucks a month 20
bucks a month not 20 bucks a month plus
100
in fees 20 bucks period done the average
person right now
saving 400 bucks a year with pure talk
usa got a plan to fit every need and
budget
here is the deal unlimited talk
unlimited text 2 gigs of data 20 bucks a
month
all you need to do grab your mobile
phone right now that you're probably
overpaying for
dial pound 250 and say keyword
michael knowles you've got to say that
magical keyword that is pound 250 to use
the way the kids
talk now hashtag two five zero say
keyword michael knowles when you do you
will say 50
off your first month you're going to
want to save that money now
because the radicals are coming for your
money a communist terrorist
angela davis just a couple months ago
endorsed
joe biden but i thought joe biden's a
moderate i thought joe biden wasn't a
socialist i thought joe biden wasn't a
radical
sure okay but
the radicals believe that joe biden will
be very
easily manipulated here's angela davis
explaining the strategy
i don't see this election as being about
choosing a candidate who will be who
will be able to lead us
in the right direction it will be about
choosing a candidate who can be most
effectively pressured into
allowing more space for the evolving
anti-racist movement that's
that's the new term they're calling it
the anti-racist movement
but ironically of course the anti-racist
movement is very racist
just like you know they always have
these misnomers they're always
projecting things
and we'll get to that because there's
some very funny evolving racism among
the anti-racist movement and some good
ways
to counter it as well but angela davis
she's a very
radical and very prominent and very
influential
left-winger she is cited by lots of
leading
left wingers she is a professor and
she's saying yeah i don't think joe
biden is some radical
but we can manipulate him we can
pressure him obviously we can the guy
doesn't know which end is up the guy
doesn't know
where he is on earth half of the time
and so you put him in
but he's not really going to be running
the show as joe biden said they're going
to take joe biden here to put him in a
home he's going to watch tv
and then the radicals are going to be
running the show bob avakian the leader
of the revolutionary communist party who
did he endorse take a guess
joe biden and i actually went to
a babavakian rally to cover it i think
there's a video of it somewhere on
youtube
these guys are burning the american flag
talking about tearing down
police stations talking about colonial
oppression i went to this thing maybe
six eight months ago
and at that time it was so ridiculous
they just looked like a bunch of idiots
now they sound like mainstream democrats
and actually as we were editing that
video i said oh my gosh this they really
are starting to sound
like mainstream democrats not because
they're moderating but because the
mainstream democrats
are radicalizing he endorsed biden too
why for the same reason
and you just need to listen to joe biden
talk for two seconds to realize that
this guy
even if he were a so-called moderate is
not going to be able to stand up to the
radical forces
in his party on his side of the aisle
joe biden was just recently
waxing philosophic about the mental
stress
of the campaigns of the presidency and
as he's trying to describe mental stress
he obviously is undergoing a lot of
mental stress can't quite get the words
out
we have to make sure we have more more
social workers and
and psychologists in our schools we have
look we learned
drug abuse isn't that doesn't cause
mental illness
mental stress and mental and
mental illness cause drug abuse we've
learned so much that we could
change so much and that's why we ought
to have to make sure
that the the super wealthy start paying
their fair share
so we can do the things we have to do to
make life better for
better for hard-working middle-class
folks so whatever
type of mental stress joe biden is
trying to fix i think
he needs to solve that in his own self
first and then he can maybe help
the rest of the country with mental
stress i don't even really know what
argument he's trying to make
he's saying drug abuse causes mental
stress or mental stress
causes drug abuse and you've got to stop
the mental stress
and you've got to i don't know something
about taxes i don't know
he's kind of all over the place when
he's on the campaign
trail because unless he's got a
teleprompter in front of him
he can't follow his own trains of
thought i mean even on simple things
he's trying to make some argument about
about i don't know mental health i guess
even though it causes mental stress
but then even a simple statement like
the pledge of allegiance joe biden tries
to recite
at a campaign event can't get through it
i pledge allegiance to the united states
of america
one nation indivisible under god for
real
one nation indivisible under god for
real you know
you know i pledge allegiance to you
to the flag of the thing under the
the you know you know the thing
this is not it's actually a good symbol
of the democratic party
joe biden isn't bumbling the pledge of
allegiance
because he hates his country and wants
to tear down the pledge of allegiance i
think he generally likes his country
he's tearing it down because he he can't
keep up
his mind is not where it should be
and so the people who do want to tear
down the pledge of allegiance the people
who
don't want to recite that the people who
do want to tear this country
to the ground they are the ones who are
gaining
power how has joe biden performed so far
the way he's done relatively well at
least in say the democratic national
convention
is he reads off a teleprompter we know
that i don't think we're telling any
tales out of school
whenever he is totally on the prompter
almost whenever he's totally on the
prompter he's okay
when he's off the prompter you can tell
that this guy
can barely string a sentence together
the trouble is
the presidency is off prompter the
presidency if you want to lead
your presidency if you want to lead the
country you've got to be the one writing
the words you've got to be the one
creating the priorities and trump is
digging
very deeply into that right now and
president trump is now focusing on
something it might be the greatest
national recognition of rot at the heart
of our country in well over a century
right he's the one seeing what's going
on he's the one leading
with joe biden someone else is writing
his lines form in the teleprompter
and sometimes that teleprompter breaks
not just in speeches
not just when he's doing a convention
apparently they're even scripting his
answers
to interviews and he can't even get
through that
they're going to be no deportations in
the first 100 days of my campaign let me
get that right
you are going to freeze deportations
freeze deportations for the first
hundred days
and then and only people will be
deported are people who committed a
felony
while here that's number one like okay i
lost that one yeah well it's
but that's good because we can we could
talk you and i on that okay uh but
but but think about think about where we
are
did you see that he so the first thing
they do poorly in this interview
is joe biden makes it clear when he's
facing the prompter and when he's facing
the question
because he's talking to the question the
question asks a question then he turns
to his left
and he's clearly reading something off
of the camera and then if that weren't
blatant enough the i guess the prompter
operator didn't get his answers up fast
enough he goes and number two uh sorry i
can't get number two yet hold on can you
get me can you
and then the interviewer tries to to
make up for it and then biden turns back
to the interviewer so it's clear
that there's a place that he's facing
when he's reading the answers and then
he turns and he faces
the interviewer he doesn't know number
two because he doesn't know what he's
running on because he doesn't know
how his administration is going to be
run because it ain't going to be run by
him there is no moderate
left anymore in effect in practice
you might have a couple guys writing
columns who say they're
but in the actual practice of politics
and government there is no moderate left
even the mainstream leftist voices are
radical including
don lemon who used to be a kind of
moderate guy on cnn
who used to talk about how yes maybe
there were some problems in the inner
cities maybe these republicans have a
point
maybe bill o'reilly has a point he used
to say that on cnn now though because
the whole left has moved so far
so far into the extreme he's not now
he's talking about blowing up the system
no matter what happens everybody's
thinking we're gonna have to blow up the
entire system
and you know what we're gonna have to do
i don't know you know what we're gonna
yes we what you have to do you just
gotta
honestly from what your closing argument
is you have to get rid of the electoral
college
because the people i don't see it
because the minority in this country
decides who the judges are and they
decide who the president is
they need a constitutional amendment to
do that and if democrats if joe biden
wins
democrats can stack the courts and they
can do that amendment and they can get
it passed well
two in the congress in three quarters of
the state legislature they may be able
to do that
maybe so don lemon first of all doesn't
understand
how laws are passed or maybe he really
understands how laws are best because
what it sounds like he's saying is
look they can stack the court and they
can do that amendment but of course the
the amendment process does not involve
the courts it doesn't come from the
courts
comes from our lawmakers and it comes
from the states
can come from the states but maybe don
lemon sees something clearly which is oh
actually the courts do make laws which
is why if joe biden wins
he's got to stack the courts but those
words we've got to blow up the system
we've got to get rid of the electoral
college
we've got to stack the courts we need to
have a full
power grab that will allow us to
arbitrarily exercise our interests
forever forever right because at that
point when when you do the things that
democrats are talking about add new
states to the country
get rid of the electoral college stack
the court
then it's not as though in five years
after that or six years after that
you're gonna have a shift of power in
the country what they're trying to do is
have
a permanent majority and i think the
phrase blow up the country is pretty apt
because that's what they've been doing
for six months they've been literally
blowing it up
they've been literally setting it on
fire they've been tearing down
our statues they've been they've been
rewriting our history
they've been blowing up our curricula
they are now threatening
not to concede the election i guess
they're promising not to concede the
election hillary clinton says joe biden
shouldn't concede under
any circumstances well here about this
circumstance
trump wins in a landslide nope not
according to hillary joe biden shouldn't
concede
under any circumstances they're already
doing that
and this didn't just begin with cnn this
didn't just begin
with some election or the biden campaign
this didn't just begin
there it began at an intellectual level
there is an intellectual
rot that has permeated the country
through the university system now into
corporate america
now even into the administrative
government that rot
comes from what is called critical
theory
critical theory and specifically what is
now
at issue is critical race theory what is
critical race theory
trump has gone out against it he just
tweeted out yesterday quote
a few weeks ago i banned efforts to
indoctrinate government employees with
divisive and harmful sex
and race-based ideologies today i've
expanded that ban
to people and companies that do business
with our country the u.s military
government contractors and grantees
americans should take should be taught
to take pride in our great country
and if you don't there's nothing in it
for you
he's basically saying we are not going
to give away
our money to people who
are seeking to destroy our country and
and the term he's using here is critical
race theory though he's referring to
sex-based ideologies as well
this is being spun by the mainstream
media as president trump
coming out against racial discrimination
training
he's saying no critical theory training
and anymore
and you know the mainstream media
actually have a point here because
critical race theory
might properly be called racial
discrimination training
it is training in how to racially
discriminate
it is it is actual training in racial
discrimination not
in anti-racial discrimination not in
anti-racism it is training
in how to be a racist and it is now
being mandated in boardrooms around the
country
in schools around the country and even
in government offices around the country
and it is
wicked and it is dumb and it is stupid
and we should get rid of it
it is a a key component
of a national rot in this country
what is critical race theory critical
race theory in particular
was developed in the 1980s it derives as
do many of these stupid left-wing
academic theories from karl marx
karl marx who famously called for
the ruthless criticism of all
that exists very simple the ruthless
criticism of all that exists
this uh this applies this criticism
to race specifically what it means is
white people bad black people good
western civilization is evil america's
evil
gotta burn it all down this is the
intellectual framework of the blm
movement
of the radical avowedly marxist
blm movement it all comes from the same
thing it's being taught in rooms all
around the country
and trump sees this national rot and we
are about to see a city go up in flames
again
i can predict it almost as surely as i
can predict the sun will rise in the
morning
what is that over it's over another
left-wing
lie we'll get to that in one second but
first i've i've got to see things
clearly
using my wonderful new prescription
glasses from coastal
coastal will allow you to get very nice
high quality prescription glasses
for as low as what do you say nine
hundred dollars
no ninety dollars no nine dollars just
nine dollars with free shipping
and 30 day risk-free returns they're
great they have a
wonderful selection you've got to go
check out their selection
but when you check it out you don't just
need to look at pictures and you don't
even need to order the glasses home
and try it on then you don't like this
and you got to go back to the store and
put the postage on
send it back you don't need to do that
they have the most advanced
virtual try on technology anywhere it's
unbelievable you can do it from your
phone you can do it from your computer
you just click the glasses you click try
it on and you can see how it looks on
your face and then you can move your
head all around and the glasses will
follow with you
and it's sized right and it's just
really really useful it will save you
hours at the store it will save you
hundreds of dollars on glasses go to
coastal.com pick the frames you want see
how they look on you
right now through october 31st they're
offering our listeners
the best deal they have anywhere you
want is 50
off your first pair of glasses coastal
dot com slash michael
see clearly with coastal.com get free
shipping 30-day risk-free returns
50 off at coastal.com michael this is
only until
october 31st c-o-a-s-t-a-l-d-o-t dot com
slash michael
some restrictions apply
i never again want to hear
that donald trump is not a true
conservative
specifically i don't want to hear that
from some egghead
accountant who says that because
trump doesn't have a total open borders
trade policy he's not a true
conservative
these squish ridiculous technocrats who
say trump's not a true
conservative because he's in any way
deviated from the policy that
republicans embraced at think tank
luncheons in 1998.
no trump trump is a conservative
trump sees this this
rot at the the heart of our
national discourse that is now bleeding
out into actual real-world violence
he sees it when most republicans don't
and he's actually doing some
something about it which most
republicans would not have the courage
to do
i don't think that a a
an administration has seen national rot
so clearly
since uh the 1850s and 60s i mean since
we were act
since the last time we were pouring
under the streets killing each other and
burning down the country
a real a real essential problem and
that's what we're talking about when we
talk about
this ruthless criticism that all that
exists
tearing down the whole country
specifically in this case applied to
race
critical race theory and its associated
pathologies
are not just destroying the country in
theory they're just running it in
practice right now
the democratic mayor of louisville mayor
greg
fischer has issued an executive order
declaring a state of emergency
state of emergency why why is there a
state of emergency
because the louisville metro police
department
is also declaring a state of emergency
why are they doing it not because of
anything that has happened
but in anticipation of an announcement
of its investigation in the brianna
taylor case who's brianna taylor
have you heard this story this is one
that the blm activists and their
lemmings on social media
have have used as the classic example
police racism and brutality
say her name brianna taylor brianna
taylor was shot
by the police this was during a no-knock
warrant and they said she was killed in
her sleep and it was so
absolutely awful of course the facts of
the case don't really correspond to that
even the no knock warrant doesn't
correspond to reality at least according
to the police who say
the issue here was they did knock and so
they knocked this gave
rihanna taylor's accomplice a time to
get a gun the guy starts shooting at the
cops then the cops start shooting back
and sadly brianna taylor is killed
we're told this one was completely
innocent then it seems actually
in the case it would appear she had
something to do with this drug
trafficking ring
so now because there's chance that the
cops aren't going to be
tarred and feathered and hanged and
drawn and quartered as as racist
murderers because maybe the facts in the
case are different than what blm was
telling us
they're declaring a state of emergency
because
they fear that blm is going to torch the
city
because probably they will because blm
has done that
in many other cities around the country
not having anything to do with justice
or injustice
just that whenever there is a signal
something about it could be a completely
justified police shooting
that's the signal to go out and torch
the city and that is based not on any
it doesn't matter what these cases say
because according to critical race
theory
in particular the country is rotten from
the core
and white people bad and black people
good and western civilization evil and
you got to tear the thing down
ruthless criticism regardless of some
particular case whenever some particular
case doesn't turn out the way the left
wants it to they say well okay
that that case doesn't prove our point
but it gets to a larger truth the
specific
claim was wrong but it gets to a larger
truth well what's the larger i don't see
any larger truth
now there is another way to fight back
against this not just
in this executive order about critical
race theory but also
in a very clever way that is going to
upset very
very many uh people in higher education
very many people on the left
now if you want to make people feel
better
not upset them but make them feel better
you should maybe have some beautiful
artwork
you should give them beautiful artwork
you should allow them to preserve a
beautiful memory you can do that
at paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price i love these
guys
i tested them out when they came on the
show because i thought it was too good
to be true there's no way
that you could get a really high quality
painting uh for
you know a reasonable price and and have
it come out the way that you want it to
i was wrong so i checked it out with my
step-brother's wedding i hadn't painted
a painting it was so gorgeous i'm now
having one done of a family member of
mine
i cannot wait to get it it is being
finished up right now
you can work with them every step of the
way so i get a proof back
and i say no i don't like this change
this change that change this
it's a it's a wonderful gift you can
give it away to someone for a birthday
for
father's day for this day for that day
you can also keep it for yourself which
is what i'm going to do this time
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer get 20 off your painting
20 off already it's already an
unbelievable value
20 off in free shipping to get this
offer text the word right now
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
to 64 000. i cannot recommend the
service highly enough
i love it and as as people who
appreciate
the finer things in life we should all
love some some beautiful art on the
walls
text michael to 64 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments
that matter most we've got into got to
get into
my favorite story that has come out of
not just higher education it might be my
favorite story
that's been in the news all week but
first
i've got to say goodbye to uh facebook
and youtube and i've got to thank our
friends over at lifelock by the way
identity theft as you know can become
you thought i was about to
send you away no first before you go
you've got to make sure you protect
yourself online
if you're like me and i know you are
then you spend a lot of time online
right now identity theft is is a big
deal because everyone's spending their
time working from home
they're doing remote learning from
schools
guess what criminal gangs are paying
attention to this they are hacking you
you can find your information sometimes
available
for sale on the dark web i'm talking
about your social security number
talking about big
stuff it's very important to understand
how cyber crime and an identity theft
affect our lives
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but you can find out if your information
is for sale on the dark web
get your free dark web scan right now
at lifelock.com knowles it's free go
over there it won't hurt there are a lot
of people trying to get your data
pick the plan that's right for you save
up to 25 off your first year
with promo code knowles that is a free
scan at lifelock.com
knowles twenty-five percent off with
promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s
head on over to the daily wire we'll be
right back with a lot more
so part of critical race theory now is
that every institution has to say that
it's racist right because
because every institution is racist
especially including
the united states because our whole
civilization is hopelessly racist and
sexist and bigoted and terrible and
unjust and blah blah blah
so if the whole system is broken
and evil then the individual
institutions have to be too and and you
see this all the time every company says
we have to do more
we are we are wrong we've been harming
people of color and we've been harming
women and we've been harming
men who think they're women and we've
been harming everybody for so many years
right
and this is just a part of the liturgy
of liberalism now
that we we always go through and you
hear it especially in higher education
so princeton university just came out
and said this they've all been saying
this for so long
president of princeton says that racism
persists
at the university and in society quote
sometimes by conscious intention
but more often through unexamined
assumptions and stereotypes
ignorance or insensitivity and the
systemic legacy
of past decisions and policies now what
he's saying this for
is to push the left-wing agenda that the
universities
now foment and then push into the
administrative government
that that runs our country so he doesn't
expect there's
a consequences it's common sense of
course we're a racist institution of
princeton
so the trump administration now the
department of education
has opened a federal civil rights
investigation into princeton
because princeton's racist and you can't
you can't have a racist institution that
discriminates on the basis of race
except for affirmative action which is
actually the law and discriminates on
the basis of race especially in higher
education but that one's okay
but you certainly can't have a an
anti-black or or
anti-woman sort of discrimination right
so
princeton in admitting this opens
themselves up to a federal civil rights
investigation i absolutely
love it they wrote you admitted
princeton's educational program
is and for decades has been racist
and so they're going to investigate
i like this because these institutions
have gotten away
with murder at least intellectual murder
at least
national murder because they they
tear down the country without any
consequence
they're lauded for they're applauded
until now
okay you're gonna implicate yourself in
racism well
okay we're gonna have to investigate you
for that i hope princeton gets
fined into oblivion i
i am a little different than many other
conservatives in that
i i know a lot of conservatives hate
higher education
they hate the liberal arts education
they say that if you have to go to
college
you know just major in engineering or
something like that do something
practical
i don't believe that i i actually i
don't think you should go to a
four-year college necessarily to study
engineering or to study some
more tangible practical skill a
technical education i think you can
probably get that somewhere else
i do think you should get a liberal arts
education i do think you should read the
great works of our civilization
i do think you should cultivate in
yourself this
this kind of understanding of our
culture you know
we always talk as conservatives about
how important the culture is
and then those same conservatives don't
want to cultivate
their their own sensibilities and their
own faculties of reason and their own
understanding of our civilization so i
think it's
very important to do all of that i love
liberal education
the problem is none of these schools
especially the elite schools like
princeton
really do that anymore they don't want
to cultivate our civilization
sometimes they do it accidentally
because of the legacies that they've got
but what they're actively trying to do
is destroy that cultivation of our
sensibilities and that
cultivation of our civilization and so
you know what i say if princeton isn't
doing
the very basic thing it's supposed to do
get rid of it get rid of it who cares
good find them into oblivion
i hope they do that and i hope harvard
and yale learn the lesson before they
get
investigated and find into oblivion too
when i think of the schools in this
country that actually do what the
schools are supposed to do what do i
think of
franciscan university of steubenville
does a good job thomas aquinas college
does a good job
hillsdale does a good job maybe st
john's i don't
how many i could i'm like on one hand
here how many universities and colleges
do we have in this country
and they're the ones fomenting the
radicalism they're shaping the minds of
young people
they are funding the administrative
state they're applying it
with statistics and data and all of the
allegedly scientific information
on which our policies are based but
they're not really scientific they're
just
political they're just radical and
extreme ain't no room for a moderate
there
okay so mitt romney you might be shocked
that
this the moderate path is to ram through
this trump nominee in an election year
i'd say that seems extreme no it's it's
just that
the extremism on the left has become
mainstream you might be shocked to hear
that the moderate path
is to go after these universities and
defund them
and find them for what they are
admitting that they're doing
but that is the moderate path that's the
only that's the only path back to any
sort of
moderate mainstream america
people have been so warped by this
nonsense they've been so radicalized
that even now on the sports channel
espn max kellerman not that i watch espn
a whole lot and i certainly don't know
that they've gone total lib but max
kellerman comes out he says
the protests are peaceful ignore what
you're seeing it's just like every other
guy on cnn and msnbc
standing in front of burning police
headquarters and they say no mostly
peaceful
little fiery but mostly peaceful he goes
out he says look they're mostly peaceful
and whenever there is violence
it's extreme right-wing agitators
a few of the things he said when he
talks about like
black lives matter 93 of the protests
are peaceful
the vast overwhelming majority are
peaceful and by the way the seven
percent that are not they have a very
broad definition of what's not quote
unquote peaceful like for example if you
block
traffic or something like that or if you
respond to police provocation
and even then a big percentage of that
which we
that wasn't peaceful is actually outside
agitators
extremist right-wing agitators posing as
protesters
in order to make the protests look bad
that's the first thing
wow brilliant analysis for mr kellerman
the protests are totally peaceful but
actually
they're violent but the violence is
caused by the cops but no actually the
violence is caused by
right-wing agitators that we never seem
to find anywhere
they're not but they're there or they
just they hide themselves and
how do they hide them they they dress up
like left-wing agitators yeah yeah
that's the ticket
yeah and then they talk like left-wing
agitators yeah and they target
all of the things that the left-wing
agitators want to destroy like the
police stations
yeah yeah that's it right-wing agitators
are tearing down statues of george
washington
and thomas jefferson and looting
businesses and stealing nike shoes and
gucci bags
and torching police stations because
right wing agitators
okay not very convincing
by the way that is obviously a
conspiracy theory right i know the left
always likes to say that
anytime conservatives breathe too
heavily we're engaging in a conspiracy
theory you know anytime
anything comes out of our mouths it's a
conspiracy theory
but i'll give you an example the left
says that there's this crazy right-wing
conspiracy theory that there's an elite
pedophile ring that involves heads of
state and royalty
and you know prime ministers and things
like that
so we say well what about jeffrey
epstein
and you know prince andrew and bill
clinton was flying all around there and
he had this bill clinton had this kind
of
nice intimate dinner with gillane
maxwell that news just broke and that
was pretty recent i was in like 2014
and you've got a lot about that i don't
know it doesn't seem like a conspiracy
theory and then the guy when they
finally arrest him
he mysteriously dies in jail and they
say it's a suicide even though
apparently none of the cameras worked
and all the guards went away uh you know
it just seems like
it's not a conspiracy theory that's a
conspiracy
right that's that's the that's the
prominent right-wing example of a
conspiracy theory
here's here's an example of a totally
mainstream left-wing story so mainstream
it's on the sports channel
all the left-wing agitators are secretly
white right-wing agitators
yeah all the guys who say they're
left-wing and and
dress up like left-wingers and torch
left-wing targets
the targets of left-wingers they're
secretly right-wingers and they're just
doing it ironically or something right
which is the conspiracy theory obviously
obviously the latter so there's no
reasoning here
okay even on the sports channel
so yeah is it is it any wonder that mitt
romney who is a model he's an actual
moderate
is it any wonder that he says gosh in
this environment i gotta choose between
these two
i guess i'm a trump guy i guess trump is
all of a sudden the moderate thing to do
the lies are outrageous and on the topic
of this supreme court nominee
we haven't seen anything yet you think
there's no way to attack
a a very qualified well-spoken
judge mother of seven two adopted from
haiti
takes your faith very seriously oh there
is newsweek
publishes a completely false story
completely false 100 bs here's the
headline
how amy coney barrett's people of praise
group
inspired the handmaid's tale
that's the whole story amy coney barrett
is part of this charismatic catholic
group called people of praise
and that group inspired the handmaid's
tale right
except it didn't so they still have the
story up
they changed the headline obviously
still the story up though correction
this article's headline originally
stated that people of praise inspired
the handmaid's tale the book's author
margaret atwood has never specifically
mentioned the group as being the
inspiration for her work
a new yorker profile of the author from
2017 mentions a newspaper clipping as
part of her research for the book
of a different charismatic catholic
group people of hope
newsreek regrets the error correction
uh yeah no margaret atwood never said
that this was true and actually then
we've got evidence that
it's we know it's not true but we're
going to keep the article up anyway
that's all you're going to see until
until the election now
which is fine by me because there are
still people in this country believe it
or not
who don't pay a ton of attention to
politics they like just live their lives
they do normal things they go to work
occasionally watch a movie or something
and spend time with their family
and they're going to see for the next
month and a half however long it is
lies the the public
destruction of a very
nice looking smart articulate qualified
mother of seven based on pure lies based
on
nothing that's what they're gonna see
and those people who maybe they call
themselves undecided independent
moderate how do you think that's gonna
push them in the presidential election
another great mark for amy coney barrett
mike lee who was also up for the supreme
court is senator mike lee from utah
i thought he'd be a great candidate for
the court i thought ted cruz would be a
great candidate for the court i've been
pushing for one of those guys great
constitutional lawyers
very clear on their thinking on the law
thought they'd be great on the court
because we would
know where they stand because they've
got this huge public record in politics
and i think it's silly to try to pretend
that
judges should never have anything to do
with politics at any point in their
career you know
for for much of this country's history
most of this country's history sometimes
people would go to the courts then
they'd go run for office
and maybe they come back to the courts
you had a president who was a chief
justice of the supreme court william
howard taft
you you have all these you had all these
guys and then all of a sudden the last
few decades
no the court you have to be on the court
for life it's like the pope you know you
shouldn't you're not supposed to be able
to resign the papacy you're supposed to
on your deathbed be still talking about
the supreme court i don't think that's
necessary i don't think that's good
and so i was pushing for the senators
mike lee is
now coming out strongly saying amy coney
barrett is a
leading choice for the court and she
should get the spot
i expect that we're going to see amy
coney barrett being picked by the
president
and i would support that nomination
wholeheartedly she's got a proven track
record
she's someone who understands the
difference
between judging and lawmaking she
understands that she's there to
interpret the law based on what the
words say rather than on the basis of
what some
social scientist or lawyer might wish
that it said
that's exactly the kind of person we
need on the u.s supreme court and i
think it will and should be her
this is an important endorsement because
lee is really strong on these con law
matters
and so if he's coming and he because he
was up for the job and and unlike
senator cruz who said i don't want the
job mike lee is
has not said that he doesn't want the
job so for him to come out and say that
it seems as though it's going to be amy
coney barrett right that this
would seem to be coordinated and it's
important to hear his opinion on it and
i'm glad he gives her a good review
so we'll we'll see president trump is
going to make that announcement on
saturday
here's what we know though if it is her
then i think the situation is going to
play out the way that i've just
described that democrats are going to so
overreach on this
it's going to turn off a lot of people
democrats might still win the election
because they might steal it in the mail
but
it's it's going to be kavanaugh part two
except
amy coney barrett is even more
sympathetic than brett kavanaugh this
milk toast lawyer
what we're seeing happen was just
expressed
in a viral video and i think this viral
video is
the perfect symbol for how the democrats
are conducting themselves on the
national level
a woman is driving her car she sees some
trump supporters rallying on the side
and she starts screaming at them and she
starts flipping them off and she starts
becoming very
very upset and then as she's screaming
she crashes into the car in front of her
here she is screaming after you up and
there's the fender bender up
whoopsie daisy and then the the trump
because the she's screaming at them
flipping them off from people like hey
hey lady how you doing
then she crashes into the car and
obviously they start laughing
and start joking about it
then you hear the cops pull up no
you're not telling me there happened to
be cops there and then the cops walk up
to her and say sorry lady that's what
the democrats are doing
they are screaming and yelling and
they're so
full of rage that
they're allowing themselves to crash
their car they're crashing their car
right into the people in front of them
causing damage and getting themselves in
a whole lot of trouble
well when your normal person is looking
at that
which side are they going to turn to all
great news
if even my man mitt is going to go
toward the trump side now
where does the rest of the country stand
that's our show i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton